29 year old left-hander from wanata
indiana and that is shamania three and
two or four point one
seven era just faced these uh halos on
sunday five eggs he allowed one run walk
two struck out six
left the game with a 4-1 lead the a's
lost the game by the final
of six to five a blown save uh behind
mania
by the bullpen so the a's and the angels
the second of four
albus andres scoops it up throws just in
time to get up
and we are officially underway
walsh 3 16 11 home runs and 37 runs
batted in
two balls two strikes outfield toward
left and wall
swings and misses down he goes on a
fastball 95 from manaya
so 2-0 the count on rindon
next delivery swings to that one and
lines it into
left field it'll be stopped on a hop by
the left fielder
tony kemp who does a good job to hold
brendon to a
single on that one he really played that
ball well out there and
rindon is on good to see a hit off of
his bat and with two out to juan logaris
who's the cleanup at her tonight will be
the next hitter the pitch to legaures is
swung out of miss up and in with a
fastball at 94.
so the angels fail to score with the a's
coming up in the bottom half
ohtani start number seven of the season
and coming into the action tonight 45
strikeouts in
30 and one third innings so he's
averaging
well over a strikeout in inning
opponents are hitting
just 154 against ohtani and he has been
lights out against
right-handed batters they are hitting
120 against him
he's allowed only six hits against
right-handed batters
in 50 at bats the world is watching
as always with shohei on the mound
breaking ball left it up lined in the
center field looking right into that sun
as lagarus
and he makes the play for the out shook
things up there and went with the
breaking ball
squared up center field throwing strikes
using his defense or hitting him hard
but right to the defenders
it's okay you're just getting a feel for
the mountain now seth brown
the right fielder who is another
left-handed batter will be stepping up
delivers and there's a swing and a miss
and he got him
a splitter there strikes out seth brown
and the inning is over so
ohtani retires three of the four he
walked the lead off manfix the next
three in a row
he's important this one is dropped down
mania hops off the pump
makes the play throws it away hustling
on around as gosselin the goose loosens
himself up right away
bunt base hit moves to second on a
throwing error yes
the goose is loose and he's in scoring
position the goose is cruising around
the bases
nice bunt here forcing sean manaya to
field the baseball and try to turn
around and throw him out
now here's the 1-2 and that's taken
outside corner perfect pitch fastball
ring him up two away
now the pitch to suzuki is a fly ball
right field play over seth brown
he's in looking forward to trying to
find her to the side and he makes the
catch
tough sunfield out there and right this
time of year
manaya works out of it here's the 01.
he swings and lines it up the middle
backhand a nice play there by lowry
throws across the body to first in time
they get him
what a sensational play by jed lowry
moving fast to his right
and back across some 95 feet on the
monte legaris
and the angels are done in the third so
jed lowry with a terrific play
saved a run and he has not allowed a hit
so far
left the slider out over the plate
spanked in the center field for a base
hit
really the one ball he has a chance to
make a good contact is a slider that
spins back on the inner half
so see if the a's can move elvis andrews
around as canna steps up
here's the 1-0 and that lookout up and
in and kind of none too happy with that
and he
looks at suzuki and he looks at otani
and suzuki trying to calm things and
larry vandover's in the middle of it now
it's getting a little more heated and
suzuki's not real happy about it he's
coming out of the dugout here come the
halos
i know it's never fun to have a fastball
run up and in on you
but i love what kurt suzuki did that's
what you want from your catcher if
you're going to have a problem with the
pitcher you're going to have a problem
with your catcher too
he's going to be his bodyguard and you
want to talk about a team that has your
back
you think the angels don't have this
man's back as a teammate
he's the ultimate teammate well and you
can see mark hannah say
that's it i'm done yeah 3-2
fastball strike three
[Applause]
you talk about tying someone up and
that's a statement in itself
right there and this last fastball 98
miles an hour shohei's best basketball
of the night he reared back and said
here's my 3-2 here
upton's at first suzuki iii big fish
right here here it is swing a double
play ball to short
elvis on the bag for one over to first
for two
and just what the doctor ordered the
angels at first and third with one out a
crisply hit ground ball
off the bottom walsh it took elvis right
to the bag and he is complete
an inning ending 6-3 double play murphy
a former third round pick of the oakland
a's in 2016
from wright state university here's the
delivery he bounces this one and it's
hit right to fletcher it's short his
throw will get him by plenty
and that is how the inning will end
snowball is two strikes too lagaras
yeah mania throws lagarres hits the
ground ball weakly left side elvis has
it
goes to second relay to first they still
turn two
i don't think it was an ideal double
play ball
chopping his way to the left side and
elvis going to the hole
and a quick feed over to lowry on the
bag and a good job in the middle by jed
now the 1-1 fish to gosselin swung on
and or
two strike [ __ ] swung out of miss
that's strike three
gosselin k is inning over we go to the
bottom of the sixth
and marcano the batter he took exception
to a pitch he was up and in
on him his last time up ohtani deals and
that inside hit him wow
no tony reacting in frustration i don't
think that was intentional at all
and mark did not react at all he just
got up and
crossed down to first base and i promise
you everything that happened the ab
before
is what was going through otani's mind
there and he has become public enemy
number one
in oakland now the infield in and
they're gonna fish to olson
first pitch is driven toward left field
up and over
upton reaches up makes the catch that's
gonna get elvis
anders home and the a's lead one nothing
on the sacrifice fly
by matt olsen so he went after the first
pitch hey sometimes the first pitch is
the best one you get to hit
the batter will be david fletcher with
the runner at
second two outs the tying run at second
david lines that one into left field
it's down for a base hit
hustling around toward the plate scoring
as rojas more time
and that is why fletch is the man you
want up there with runners and score in
position
little flair gets a second on the
attempted fun
single and now fletch coming through
so six and two-thirds innings tonight
for sean manaya unfortunately he's going
to sit down he's going to be
disappointed
madden stays with otani 1-1 game in the
seventh two on nobody out for chapman
so nice opportunity for the a's here
after the angels tied it in the top of
this inning
swung on bouncing ball through the left
side of base it lowered a third they're
going to wade him home
it's bobbled by upton and he will score
standing up
it's 2-1 oakland as chapman delivers the
single to left field
and once he bobbled the ball the team
with the worst defense in the league and
opened the door for the ace to regain
the lead
the night is done for ohtani and murphy
stands in he has struck out and he's
bounced to short
and that's going to be a base hit left
center field murphy comes through
as moreland will score chapman to third
and it's three to one
this is reminiscent of what they did
last night put together an inning with a
bunch of good at-bats
so here's jose rojas
rojas on the first pitch sky's one
toward cannon
cannon looking up cannon grabs it and
that is the ball game
luke trevino gets to save a night of
really good pitching